Tengo: "Resuelve para x y y mediante el método
de sustitución", y aquí tengo dos ecuaciones:
-x - y = 1, x = -3y - 9. Y, bueno, pues justo aquí
acabo de copiar esas dos ecuaciones, aquí en mi
blog de notas. Así que vamos a trabajarlas justo
por aquí. Dice -x - y = 1 y x = -3y - 9. Ahora
quiero que te des cuenta que cuando nos dicen que
utilicemos el método de sustitución lo que tenemos
que hacer es despejar una de las dos variables y
sustituirla en la otra ecuación. En este problema
ya nos están dando despejado a la variable x,
nos dicen que x es exactamente igual que -3y -9,
es decir, que puedes sustituir este valor de x,
este valor que tengo aquí, en mi primera ecuación,
¿y por qué puedo hacer eso? Bueno, porque recuerda
que al final lo que buscamos es un valor para x,
y un valor para y que cumplan ambas ecuaciones,
por lo tanto, esta x, el valor que tome esta x
en esta ecuación de abajo va a ser exactamente el
mismo que el valor que va a tomar x en esta parte
de arriba, por lo tanto puedo sustituir, y es más
déjame ponerlo así, puedo sustituir a x, a esta
x de aquí, por este valor que tengo acá, porque
tiene que ser la misma x. Y ahora sí, utilizando
el método de sustitución lo que hay que hacer es
sustituir el valor de x que ya tenemos despejado,
en este caso, en la otra ecuación en donde no
tenemos despejado a x. Y quiero que te des cuenta
que ahorita que reemplacemos el valor de x por
-3y - 9 en la primera ecuación, entonces me va a
quedar una ecuación que solamente depende de y, es
decir, me va a quedar que esta primera ecuación la
puedo ver de la siguiente manera. Lo voy a poner
aquí: -x, pero x vale, o bueno, pero x vale -3y
-menos 3y-, -9, entonces me va a quedar -x, pero
x vale -3y -9, ¿y cómo sé eso? Es la información
que me da la segunda ecuación. Ok. Esto -y tiene
que ser igual a 1. Estoy utilizando la ecuación de
arriba y estoy sustituyendo el valor de x. Y ahora
sí, me quedaría -déjame ponerlo con este color-:
menos por menos más me va a quedar 3y, menos por
menos más me va a quedar más 9, -y, esto es igual
a 1, o dicho otra manera, 3y - y es lo mismo que
2y + 9, esto es igual a 1, o dicho de otra manera,
si yo resto 9 de ambos lados de esta ecuación, voy
a restar 9 aquí y voy a estar 9 aquí-, entonces,
de este lado estos dos se cancelan y me queda que
2y = 1 - 9, 1 - 9 es lo mismo que -8, un 9 menos 1
con signo negativo. Ok. Y ahora, si yo divido todo
entre 2, esta parte entre 2 y esta parte también
entre 2, estos dos se van a cancelar, y me va a
quedar que y = -4 - 8 / 2 es -4, y ya tengo el
valor de y. De lujo. Ahora recuerda que no hemos
acabado, lo que necesitamos también es el valor de
x, y para encontrar el valor de x puedo utilizar
la ecuación de arriba o la ecuación de abajo,
pero en la ecuación de abajo ya tengo despejado
a x, por lo tanto, ¿qué te parece si la copiamos
aquí? x = -3y - 9, y sustituimos el valor de y
que es el que ya tenemos, es decir, que x = -3y,
pero y habíamos dicho que vale -4, -4, y todo
esto -9, -9. Ok, dicho de otra manera: x = + 12,
3 por 4 es 12, menos por menos es más, - 9, o x =
3, de lujo, x = 3 y y = -4. Y vamos a corroborar
en las dos ecuaciones a ver si en efecto llegamos
a la solución. Comprobemos en la primera ecuación:
-x, o es me va a quedar -3 -y, menos y es menos,
pero y vale -4, menos menos 4, esto es igual a 1.
Ok, y aquí me quedaría que-3 + 4 = 1, lo cual es
cierto, 4 - 3 es 1, de lujo. Y vamos a probar en
la segunda actuación, dice: x, es decir, 3 es
lo mismo que -3y, que vale -4, ok, -9, y aquí
me quedaría que 3, 3 = 12 positivo -9, lo cual es
cierto. Entonces se cumplen las dos ecuaciones:
cuando x vale 3 y y vale -4 se cumplen ambas
ecuaciones. Vamos a escribirlo aquí en nuestro
navegador de internet. Así que lo voy a poner
aquí, x = 3, y = -4, x = 3, ok, y = - 4, ok. Y es
hora de comprobar respuesta, comprobemos, de lujo,
estamos bien. Nos vemos en el siguiente video.